omg you look like a vision tonight thank
you so much you have just knocked it out
of the park this entire press tour do
you feel like you are taking notes from
selena kyle as you were making your way
through i mean i have literal cats on my
dress what do you think
thank you very much you feel like she's
kind of transforming your own personal
life as well maybe i think just someone
who i've been inspired by for so long
i'm so excited to celebrate her on this
on this journey of releasing the film
incredible what previous cat women
because obviously we've seen other
adaptations and iterations what classic
cat ladies did you look to to kind of
put together your own vision and your
approach to this iconic character i was
inspired by all of them really the way
that each and every one from julie
newmar to earth a kit hallie and
michelle all of them they completely
owned the character and made made the
character their own and i was inspired
by by the fact that they all did their
thing with it and you did too young lady
for sure and i love to see all the hype
you're getting on social media it is
well deserved of course i'm talking
about jason and channing two of your
guys in your fam giving you a shout out
what does it mean to have them in your
corner giving you that support well you
know we're in new york tonight and i
live here i have a lot of friends and
family here tonight so i feel very lucky
to have a lot of people who love me here
today i know but i saw the fam here so
it's nice to have their vacuum he's
right there there he is it's wonderful
[Music]
you